You know guys Fortnite has really
become a phenomena. And a lot of you out there
love the game, others not so much,
like me. But you know what I really hate
about Fortnite, is when some
disrespectful dude kills you and busts
out the worm or dabs on you. I mean is a
dab even a dance? That doesn't make any
sense. And what is this? What is that? What is the name for that? Why are we doing
this list? This game isn't even an esport
yet. In fact, can we just do another like
CS:GO Top 10 or something? I did- did you
just sprinkle salt on me?
Here are the Top 10 Most Annoying Fortnite Dances/Emotes.
We're starting off our list with a
throwback to the famous Carlton dance.
This dance has made an appearance in
countless video games, and Fortnite is
no exception.
And while at first you may get hit with a rush of nostalgia, it’s not unusual for one to be tilted by this
over the top dance move from Bel Air’s nerdiest son.
You see a player ahead of you. No skin. No cover. Standing still.
"We got ourselves a bogie, he's a default skin, which means bad."
If that player turns on you he’ll likely bust out the ninth entry on our list.
The base dance in Fortnite has its roots in the NBC show Scrubs.
What could hurt more than being bested by a ‘frugal’ gamer who refuses to shell out V-Bucks for a slick dance.
Sometimes Fortnite is exciting and the eighth most annoying dance on our list is the perfect way to show your appreciation for your own skills.
The aptly named Jubilation gives you a chance to rub your happiness right in your opponents face.
Whether it’s a victory royale, Elaine coming home from holidays, or beating the Texas Rangers
this dance shows your victim just how happy you are to have bested them.
The seventh dance on our list is the most obvious choice for those truly stylish plays.
Dropping that sweet robotic pop after downing an enemy team certainly has a classy feel to it.
And with all that mechanical proficiency on display, sometimes you just need to execute dance sequence.
You may not be able to call our sixth entry a “dance” but it makes up for it in pure, rage inducing B.M.
This emote lets you show your enemies that you know just how much they hated getting out played by you.
If it’s one thing Fortnite has plenty of it’s Sodium Chloride, and no one is stopping you from spreading a little more.
If you’re getting annihilated by a four man squad, you know they’re best mates when they all drop the number five dance.
"Just perfect view to watch that whole thing buh. I'm just chilling in the tree, just kind of like."
Popularized by Marlon Webb and his gang of outlandish joggers the Best Mates dance brings the energy to your best Fortnite moments.
Fortnite has proven that it’s popularity can breathe life back into any meme.
Flopping its way to number four is the funkiest dance on our list.
When you really need to rub it in dropping this classic 80’s breakdancing move on your opponent's is sure to get in their heads.
"Oh. I hate my life. Bro, bro they're doing the worm on me. Both of them. And they put a campfire here."
"These guys are d**ks."
Trying to pull this move out at your friends birthday party might not be a smooth move,
but after the Victory Royale nothing could be smoother.
The third place spot on our list belongs to the mesmerizing, arm flailing, floss.
This dance has become a sensation after appearing on SNL and took the Fortnite community by storm.
With it’s surge of popularity there’s no shortage of players flossing after an impressive kill.
It’s simple. It’s effective. And it’s everywhere. Our runner up dance is the dab.
Okay, maybe it’s dance status is a bit questionable but its social pervasiveness certainly isn’t.
If you’re looking for the simplest move to send your enemies straight to tilts-ville then this needs to be your go to move.
Every part of the dance that takes our number one spot screams annoying.
From the music to the absurdity of the moves,
it’s impossible to stay composed after losing a duel and seeing this.
This blood boiling taunt is easily the most annoying dance in Fortnite.
Oh yeah, it also may be the most recognizable Fortnite dance IRL,
even before making an appearance in the 2018 World Cup Finals.
That's our list for this week guys. And don't worry about Colin his sodium levels are a little bit elevated.
But I'm sure he'll be back to
normal for next week's episode.
It's not a dance Josh, it's not a dance.